how the hell I don't got that long a
lifespan anyway
[Music]
now I'm standing y'all happy we're all
standing up now bunch of jackasses
standing in a circle
the stone reacts to anything organic is
a bigger the target the bigger the power
surge all Ronan's got to do is touch the
stone to the planet's surface and saft
all plants animals Nova Corps everything
will die
so Ronan does not make the surface
rocket will lead a team to blow a hole
in the dark asters starboard hole then
our craft and yondu's will enter won't
there be hundreds of the current
soldiers inside
I think of Saqqara newspaper people
once they know we're on board
Ronin will isolate himself behind
impenetrable security doors on desk
which I can disable by dismantling the
power source we'll make it to the flight
deck and I'll use the Hadron enforcer to
kill Roman once rolling is dead we will
retrieve the stone use these devices to
contain it if you touch it it will kill
you I'll contact one of the Nova
officers who arrested us
hopefully they'll believe we're there to
help there's one more thing we need to
complete the plan that guy thought no no
we don't know we don't need that guy's
eyes no seriously I need
minutes remember what got the end of all
this I get the stone you cross me
[Music]
[Music]
a terrible plan now you're the one who
said he wanted to die among friends
you